hi everyone
you look so great i see your signs
and your kids and your animals oh
excellent i see a t-shirt i love it you
guys look so
fantastic has anyone been watching the
bachelor i'm trying to like game this
thing i want to get
an involved social experiment is anyone
a bachelor fan
alyssa yes i love
that show oh my gosh okay do you have
any predictions for this season
oh i really love blake blake's my
favorite
right now but i i have a feeling that
we're going to end up getting yeah she's
going to end up with dale she really
loves dale
that's that's for sure okay blake
alyssa's money's on blake i like this
thank you alyssa so much
[Applause]
oh and jonathan and logan you guys look
familiar
you've been here before hello
hi there now i'm gonna do a thing for
the weekender because it's friday do you
have any fun weekend plans
this weekend is our four-year
anniversary so um
dinner and really excited about that
what do you guys get to cook good
question do you have any recommendations
you know what i just got a copy of aina
garten's new
cookbook modern comfort food oh my gosh
it's incredible i highly recommend well
there we go
you can't go wrong with aina oh my gosh
i can't believe i asked what you were
gonna do this weekend it's your four
year anniversary how perfect
you